TORONTO GETS WITH THE RIGHT HAN
STAYING RIGHT WITH HIM.
WE WILL STAY AND GET A PENALTY
CALLED THE PLAY AS WELL, THOUGH
IT IS COLORADO ZONE.
NOW, WATCH HERE AS WE ARE GOING
TO STOP IT. 13 OF THEM,
IN.
BUT IT SQUIRTS OUT TO CENTER
ICE.
AND D TAMPREBOUND, AND A STOP O
ORGANIZED AND FINDING THE
DEFENSIVE RESPONSIBILITIES AS
HE, COLORADO CAME SAVE
PERCENTAGE.SAFE.
NOW, SERGE READ THE PLAN CAME
OVER.
ON THE BURAKOVSKY
STEEL.
>> Randy: AGAIN, WITHIN FRONT.
WOW, JOHANSSON COMES OVER TO
MAKE THIS A. OH,  SLICK K FOR T
.  GETS ANOTHER SLIDE.
BENNETT SHOOTS, YOU EXACTLY
WHY  THIS GOAL HAPPENED, AND HE
WAS ABLE TO GET IT INPOWER PLAY
BARKOV NEEDS IT.
CENTERING INTO IT.
WAS A SHAKEN UP, NOW HE
REJOINED THE PLAY, CENTERING
FEED, AND THAT IT ALLOWS BOBROV
UP.
OH SOUTH
FLORIDA.
TORONTO HAS TWO AVALANCHE
PLAYERS ON THEM, AND AWAY WITH
GAVE  HIM A SHOT.
HE DID NOT ON THE
OUTCOME OF THIS GAME.
>> THAN THE POST, AS WELL ON +2
TO GO BACK TO OPENING-NIGHT
FOUR GAMES AGO, FROM LATE IN
THE THIRD PERIOD UNTIL THIS WAS
FOR A CALL AND COMING.
AND  MARCHMENT THE CENTER, COUR
THE DRAW.
IT WORKS.
FACE-OFF, DEEP IN THE